[MUSIC PLAYING]
When you're a smaller
competitor taking
on the big guys,
you have to come up
with fun, sometimes outrageous
ways of getting your brand
known, getting on
the front pages,
because you just don't
have the advertising spend
that the big guys.
Try to do things that
make people smile,
even if you make a
fool of yourself.
Taking notes has been the
most important thing that I've
done in building businesses.
I went to space and it was
an incredible day in my life.
But I had a list
of 35 things that I
felt need to be improved upon.
When I was floating,
I felt there
should be a handle on the
seats that go on the walls
that you could grab hold of.
If I hadn't written some
of these things down.
I would have
forgotten about them.
I'd already forgotten about
them until I just read them now.
By yourself a notebook.
People who use the I-word
too much put people off,
and rightfully so.
If you're in a team of
people, it's very important
that you talk about
us or we, or try
to avoid the I-word unless
it's absolutely necessary.
And your business is likely
to excel as a result.